Marc Spears here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you mark I'm better than the
Warriors well let's start with it came
from a knee surgery but I'm okay I'm
moving okay very good now that's the way
we start a Honda inside rapport there we
go he's coming out with his own is
reporting on your own status Marc Spears
here on the show so you spoke with curry
after last night's game where they
called it what a strain adductor is it a
groin injury what's going on with him
more it's a groin injury after the game
in the locker room he was walking very
gingerly walk very slow and I've never
seen him and in all the years living in
Oakland with him around him in a locker
room for so long it's like mother and
it's a shoe guy and a couple of his
friends were waiting for him his agent
he was there for at least 90 minutes
after the game just kind of you know
taking everything in get treatment and I
was able to get him as he was walking
out and the one thing is look we're used
to him but it's having ankle injuries
having knee injuries this is a groin
injury this is a new injury for him so
he was telling me like look it was an
ankle I have an idea how long I'd be out
but with a groin I've never had this
before so while the Warriors are not
expecting it to be a long-term injury I
do expect him to miss games and be
cautious because he's not sure how he's
supposed to feel when he's right and so
last night's loss if you even want to
call it that I mean it wasn't even close
oh man how deep are they the Bucks got
their number for some reason man it's if
you look back it's this is a new thing
with the Bucks I think their athleticism
in length it's a good calendar for them
hmm okay so let's get into this a little
bit here because I've already given the
trophy to the Warriors
well what date was it Chris Brown when I
did it on the show October 30 yeah
October 30 I know if you missed that
ceremony a mark but oh okay yeah in
spirit
so I see really how how do how should we
view this loss well I mean like last
year the books it wasn't as bad but they
beat him in in Golden State and Yanis
got the better of Durant even as great
as Durant is and he's always played well
against the lawyers and they if I'm
other NBA teams i I started looking at
those Bucks games because it's their
athleticism and their length that the
lawyers seem to have trouble with them
you know the Bucks who might have more
length than anybody in the league and so
there's a small sample size but it's an
interesting sample size like look it's a
long ways away to the finals
do I think the Bucks are gonna get there
have a shot I really sought to wrote
like Toronto better right now I I like
Boston better but they're they're one of
the teams in the mix and if for some
reason they're gonna you know match up
with the Warriors I mean yes it'd be
hard to beat on four times but the
Warriors would have a lot to have to
figure out from a length and and
athleticism standpoint because what the
Bucks have is definitely a menace to
them Marc Spears of the undefeated right
here on the Rich Eisen show in the Honda
inside a report yes you said that other
teams should take a look at the Bucks
tapes because of their athleticism and
length there's only one Yanis though and
the books the Bucks right the Bucks have
him would you say with I guess one
eighth of the season gone by that he's
your frontrunner for MVP in the league
mark I'll give you an odd name okay um
Kyle Lowry
I mean they have the best record in the
league he's averaging a double-double
he's averaging like 17 and 11 as well as
like five rebounds he obviously is dealt
with a lot of turmoil up there
so perhaps there's some sentimental
value to that choice as well but um the
way
he's helped this kind of not only be a
seamless transition from Kauai to
DeRozan but he's uh me vice versa but he
kind of pushed them to a higher level
with co-op and I've been I've been
hearing whispers of Steve Nash kind of
season it's probably too early for that
man that makes him uncomfortable to hear
that but he's my early pick right now
interesting and that's your latest piece
on the undefeated calm Kyle Lowry
promises not to get too emotional when
DeRozan and Casey return to Toronto as
Dwane Casey the former code the reigning
coach of the year returns with the
Pistons so so you say it's not really
Kauai in Toronto it's Lowry is what we
should be looking at at 11:00 and 1:00
correct yeah yeah you know I think a lot
of times these guys that don't do
backflips dunks and crossover threes and
often time to get overlooked but he's
leading that league in assists
you know he's scoring he's making
everybody better
he's helped Kauai have a seamless
transition um you know is it flashy or
we don't see a highlight reel probably
not but to average like eighteen eleven
and five and knock down threes and make
other players better
you know there's deeper statistics that
even if you really look behind the
screen to me it shows that he's having a
phenomenal season
well pay off and and then you got the
record to boot I mean right 11:01 it's
nothing to see that so let's return to
the Western Conference in a few minutes
we have left here the Thunder in the
earlier part of the TNT double-header
last night beat the harden and Paul back
on the floor rockets by 18 what's up
with the Rockets Marcus what do you
think look I know their defense is bad
right now but right they did and
Westbrook wasn't even in the game missed
his second straight game handed it's
confusing
lemon can't harden and
Chris Paul just kind of do that nurse
which means I looked at trevor ariza
loss was huge but I expected to have you
know this much of an aftereffect he's
kind of like there where he was there
draymond Green I mean there's so much he
could do and there's so much that people
didn't pay attention to he would guard
point guards as they were bringing the
ball up the court he rebounds he does
all the little things but that isn't the
reason why their offense was bad
yesterday it's a very curious confusing
situation and I'm sure the Warriors are
sitting back like whoa we didn't expect
it they actually play next week next
Thursday very interesting game coming up
and I'm sure the Warriors would love
nothing more to go in there and drill
them but they'll probably be going out
there without Steph Curry
I expect draymond Green to be back
Monday against the Clippers and by next
Thursday expect Shaun Livingston to be
back as well so that that matchup in
Houston will be very intriguing for a
lot of reasons
yeah D'Antoni called the offense anemic
last night and then there's the Celtics
and then there's Boston which would had
to pull one out of their duck boat last
night to force overtime in Phoenix and
and win that game how concerned are you
about the the Celtics Kyrie said don't
worry we got at Brad Stevens we're gonna
get it and what say you Marc Spears well
my concern levels not as bad as this for
Houston they'll figure it out the Utah
game will be interesting we board and
we're going back but I am surprised that
they're playing like this yeah I saw him
in the preseason last year and Charlotte
and they were outstanding and amazing
and this was before Jordan got hurt so I
mean do they have just too many cooks
you know what I mean like too many guys
that need the ball it's but it's early
and we got to remember they still got to
get used to playing with this group of
guys they got more air for Mars in the
Eastern Conference I think they'll be
fine but what they
the risk of if they continue to have a
bad started but as we see right now
Milwaukee's the truth Milwaukee is good
and Toronto is good so what if Boston
Falls for the third seed like you do not
want to be one of those three teams is
going to be in a third seed and it's not
going to be an envious position in fact
bridge if we look at it the number two
seed might be the best seed needs to
conference right mm-hmm I mean the
number one seed is I'm sorry to Betsy
because those two and three in the
second round it's going to be a battle
royal man and whereas the team that's
number one
they'll probably close to the Eastern
Conference Finals so now there's a much
stronger president as we haven't seen in
a long time in the Eastern Conference to
get the number one seed to get away from
that second-round matchup and Boston's
gonna make it very difficult for
themselves to do it even though it's
it's early hmm and last one for you I
know as you mentioned no and you say
that the Bucks they appear to be for
real and we got to nine when teams and
the Nuggets and Blazers in the West but
if I did not ask you about the Lakers I
would have my host card removed for me
Marc Spears okay so in Sacramento what
they did with Tyson Chandler like keep
an eye on stuff like that like I think
that anytime some veteran gets let go or
ask for a buyout or something like yes
they're gonna be a candidate the same
way the Warriors have been in recent
years and Houston has been and when the
trade deadline passes and there's some
bet there's always two or three good
veterans sitting there that kid that
could help a team they're gonna add
pieces there give me couple names that
you might be targeting on that front
right now Marc what do you say oh I
haven't finished my coffee yet rich but
uh next time I'll be ready for new
surgery I get it no coffee so please
continue your thought that go ahead but
not the thing I think about them and
maybe I'm cavalier about it
I got four years with LeBron James right
I I think that they should move somebody
young talent and get to get a star I
mean I haven't heard their name in the
Jimmy Butler sweepstakes I don't think
he wants to go there dare I say should
they try to get a job wall you know
kawatche things fine so you're not going
to get him but I just think if your
window with LeBron is four years I don't
know man that yeah I'm probably good I'm
not the GM but I can't be patient with
that I'm doing like the Yankees I'm
going for broke now I'm making a move
now to try to make that team a contender
and even with as great as the addition
is to just pick up for nothing at Tyson
Chandler it doesn't make the Warriors
shake in their boots yeah I know isn't
it amazing mark that that the whole idea
when he signed when LeBron signed he's
like I'm not doing a series of one-year
deals with options I'm giving you three
plus one so let's all just be patient
like know what it is and look even
Michael Jordan at some point turn the
other way as a player I remember seeing
him in Washington we never see any
Washington highlights rich why because
he wasn't great then it was at the end I
remember of a Sean Leonard walking his
shot and standing over him on the floor
and I think it was the first voshon
lenard don't be mad at me yes my boy I
might've hit the first block shot of his
career you know he was a three-point
shooter and so in four years
I mean look maybe with LeBrons a robot
he'll never like digress but I think the
Lakers need to be aggressive now and
trying to get a championship contender
team around them Marc love our chats man
love your work check it out on the
undefeated and appreciate the time let's
talk down the line
you too thanks I appreciate that mark
Jay Spears ESPN on Twitter I follow them
you should as well the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience